[Music]
[Applause]
i'm very grateful val's been amazing
he's very tough he's very intense but
it's been great we we haven't been
having fun at all
like not at all everyone's just so sweet
and i'm i'm i just want to hug them all
and cheer for them all which is probably
like not that's just how i roll but um
yeah it's really cool i am i'm just
going to go and hug everyone be the
designated hugger on this cast i've said
a million times i'll say it a million
more times i'm so grateful that they
trusted me with victoria
i would have been very upset if she was
given to anybody else so i'm grateful
for the for the challenge for the
opportunity this is a very
unique special
partnership i'm really blessed that was
an incredible human being an incredible
dancer and i just feel really honored
that that we're going on this journey
together she she's been through so much
and her life has been
many many challenges i want this to
to be full of laughter and smiles and it
won't be you know it'll be a lot of
challenges still ahead of us but i want
this to celebrate her will her celebrate
her strength and spirit and hopefully in
the process we can inspire other people
i think in my heart i just want to wear
sparkles all the time i love bright
colors i think it's fun it's happy
you've got great music you've got lights
you what more could you ask for
[Music]